now turning from the ice to the diamond
the discussions continue tonight on a
possible Stadium for the A's lawmakers
in Carson City in committee this
afternoon hearing public comments on the
bill to fund the A's new baseball
stadium but as you're about to hear not
everyone thinks of this as a good move
for Vegas eight news now reporter
Madison Kimbrough live tonight Madison
with those details
some describe this as a key asset along
the Las Vegas Strip as you can see we're
right in front of the Tropicana hotel as
many weigh in on the possibility of a 30
000 seat 1.5 billion dollar retractable
dome stadium that's set to be built here
last Friday Governor Lombardo's office
introduced Senate Bill 509 a stadium
funding bill heard during a joint
meeting in the Senate finance committee
and the assembly's Ways and Means
Committee this proposed bill would give
the A's 380 million in Public Funding
180 million would come from the state
Clark County contributing 145 million
that money coming from bonds at the
county would have to repay some locals
not too keen on all of that money being
spent and others feel like it was a
strategic move to have this meeting on a
holiday and now all of a sudden at the
last minute of the legislature they
spring this plan to spend 500 million
dollars there's a baseball stadium in
Summerlin that seats 10 000 people the
average attendance at the rate at the
excuse me at the A's games and Oakland
is only 8 000 and recently some of the
games have only had 2 000 people there
they're trying to pull a fast one on us
and as a voter as a resident Nevada I do
not appreciate it at all the other 25
million would come from a special tax
District in and around the stadium tax
credits intended to be paid over a
five-year span of 36 million dollars a
year starting at the end of 2024. but
while some are against the stadium being
built others believe it's exactly what
Vegas needs but the city quickly
becoming a prime Sports Hub I understand
the opposition to what people are
considering to be a gift of taxable
funds what they're not seeing is the
full picture of this when you look long
term in the future this is going to
create revenue for restaurants and
hotels that Stadium can be used outside
of baseball for other for other things
and as for our County Commissioners take
on today's meeting commissioner Jim
Gibson who oversees this District said
quote the financial terms are reflective
of Clark County's prudent Financial
practices to help protect Clark County's
general fund and the property taxes of
our residents I respect the
legislature's due diligence as they
review this bill in the coming days now
it should be known that the hearing for
this bill is not over and a final vote
will be set once the session is over
that's going to be around the beginning
of June reporting live here on the Strip
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now